so I've got seven days to buy a house in
the United States of America using of my
own
[Music]
so that was a tough day yesterday that
was probably the most rejected I felt in
10 years it reminded me of when I was 17
and I was starting out in proper size we
need to rethink what we get what on
earth we're gonna do and have it how
we're gonna how are we even gonna get
inside houses because without talking to
people that actually want to sell their
house in a serious how we're gonna get a
deal are I don't know yeah I don't know
Matt you said it certainly this is hard
everyone everyone's seen how America's
easy it is really it's really tough if
you think about it if you ring in a
state agent you say all kind of even in
England and you said kind of make a
doing normally they block oh yeah okay
we can you next week that's no good for
us cuz we need to get into the houses
now they're buying houses out here for
like 16 ground spend your 10 grand on
them and then selling them for 100 and
then I'm covered trying to do a lease
option agreement on them well they're
not interested I yeah what's they are
because they're not they've got so made
so much money already I'm struggling to
find motivated sellers got stuck
pyruvate anyone's phoning me back now
yesterday was really horribly annoying I
was winging everybody known was
answering I must have made about I think
it was 112 calls I dialed out and I
spoke to about nine people which sucked
someone was calling me
they could be phoning me back to give me
the house hello can I help
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay my name's back and now yeah boy
hoarders what I'm looking at it's on for
$85,000 what do you think is worth do
you think it's worth about sure sorry
what do you think you would rent out for
as it is if I bought it for $85,000 and
rented out what dirt can fetch for well
that sounds cool I mean I'd love to have
a look around it and maybe meet another
chat about what you've got are you are
you free tomorrow no chance
[Laughter]
[Music]
well I mean maybe we can meet up on
table Brown is this property if it is if
it looks good maybe we could maybe we
could meet like tonight or something or
tomorrow so what did you say your name
was Marvin great name I look forward to
see I look forward to meeting you and
looking around the house layer chairs
Marvin god bless oh no he just said that
this property he's selling it but he
said that the owner has got a big
mortgage of about sixty thousand and
they they really just want to
mortgage and that's that I'll just take
over the mortgage
I'll just take over the mortgage give
him a little monthly payment and rent it
out myself
it would run out for about a thousand
pound a month thousand dollars a month
so if I just give him a couple hundred
pound a month clear their mortgage by
taking it on agree to buy it for 85 down
the line I think we do like a deal with
that exciting times
[Music]
so we're here how they made an important
the 10 a.m. we've got another one at
11:00
she's the lady called this morning the
agent who sounded really nice and said
can we change it to 10:30 we're a bit
pushed go on just about it's not a
quarter to 11:00 and she's still not
here do you know like when you're trying
to get somewhere you like hit everything
so when we walked into this property it
was immediately obvious that we needed a
lot of money to be spent on the property
[Music]
how would how would someone get this is
a family house right it was left to them
and Wow
so they had people like comest and
somebody came in bought their stuff and
stored it here so now in this part of
Philadelphia you can make a lot of money
by buying cheap fixing up and selling
and I definitely think this will be a
fantastic investment property if you
have some money to start off with doing
this up and it was done to a pretty
decent standard how much do you think
[Music]
this is my personal opinion because it's
such a good house like you know what I
mean you really could sell it to
somebody you know I wouldn't do rooms I
don't know why I think it just kind of
takes away from sharing stuff we're here
sounds like though take them
I think it would the only way would work
would be if you did it as a joint
venture but she could do that the estate
agent the broker I think that she should
really try and do this as a joint
venture where she does all the work she
oversees it and get someone else to put
the money in in fact I even suggested
that she do that I can't really see what
a value I'm going to bring to this this
project and I certainly can't see that
I'm gonna be able to do it with no money
for this challenge we have no money at
all so it's definitely not gonna work
for us you subscribe to my youtube
channel that is so cool and what do you
think of it did you like it
[Music]
he he record everything I plan to follow
me and recall me every everything I do
he records me when I'm taking a shower
and maybe not shower but it's a lot
better than it was yesterday
ya know of him and he's just text aside
he's gonna meet us there which is really
good we were gonna lock ourselves in but
he's gonna he's gonna meet us there it's
always good to meet the owners and the
agents because sometimes they have other
properties so really excited about this
property because I know there's negative
equity so I'm going to really try and
pitch a lease option agreement even if
it's through the agent I'm gonna try I'm
really going to go for a lease option
agreement now so let's see what happens
with were leave your pets
I'm installed but it was just
[Music]
this property is actually the perfect
property for a lease option agreement
the seller he doesn't want to be a
landlord he's got no equity in it at all
so even if he sells it for what he wants
which is about sixty five thousand
pounds while the Tories paid his
transfer fees his broker fees he's going
to be left with nothing in his pocket
[Music]
only problem is that there's an estate
agent in the way now as it happens
Marvin who's the estate agent he's a
really nice guy he's happy to speak to
the seller on our behalf but the
challenge is gonna be trying to get well
he's pretty motivated there is a matter
of a mortgage that needs to be met
obviously for to be happy to walk away
and maybe walk away with almost 60 K
nearly 57 I believe okay so he basically
and we often if we offered 57 possibly
if you could offer a little higher
because I think he want to walk away
with just a little bit of cash maybe
just a couple grand
I mean the thing is we looked up our
property about three speeds away there's
in similar condition which is like 60 K
okay well I mean we can be flexible as
possible with the numbers well you know
same time you know yes the he must have
meet so basically we just if we just
walk around very little in his pocket he
must walk why with this property gone
yeah Phoebe can happen to be very happy
happy man I don't get why doesn't just
work it out I think he's mad at least
option agreement
how much you get this house to be
working - yes - years easily 200 okay
okay so we've got an option to buy it
for 75 or 85 and we refurbed it and then
in two years you don't want to buy
actually house that house that I lost
for him yeah well then wait but then we
lived with then we we've just we've just
spent thousands of dollars on a property
for nothing and then he just takes it
back and then you sell it for a higher
price won't just be problem Academy
depends on what he wants to do I mean if
he just wants to get rid of this
property and it doesn't want anymore we
can take it we can take it on we can
take over the mortgage we can give him
the price he wants duck down the line if
it's fine if he does then that's also
fine I'm pretty confident if I was able
to speak to the seller direct I'll be
able to get a deal with this property
but that's the only challenge so I'm
really crossing my fingers and hoping
that this is the one you guys aren't
from the area you don't know the area so
how will you know how to put a quality
tenant in this property that you can
actually manage from a distance I think
he would rather just take the cash offer
we've also got you know people come and
still have showings I still have
interest yes well show round show them
around okay if you can't sell it let me
stuck we cannot even catch another like
maybe 50 55 no no no all we can take
over is mortgage I really appreciate you
my phone oh thank you very much after a
lot of hustling sometimes it's good to
just take a break and have a little rat
breathe
[Music]
- don't know how we're gonna do this
really really hard
what a day to be a
I mean we get nervous on that side if
northern works is still to happen it
will happen
we have an exceptionally and then he has
a renter rent on it